Heidi Klum may have had everybody beat
in the costume department now Rachel
Smith got the slimy exclusive
[Music]
you know what they say the early bird
catches the worm we're going fishing
Tom when you married Heidi did you think
that you were marrying into this a
Halloween spectacle I I always loved
telling me myself so yeah I was ready
for it you could say Heidi's husband
took the bait hooked Line and Sinker and
the queen of Halloween's brainworm
costume left me completely floored I
have never done an interview like this
before Heidi and even triggered a slew
of online memes like me when I don't dye
my eyebrows
well what was amazing for me today
didn't take me so long but to make the
costume took a very long time the
costume construction took months to
build but as we see in this behind the
scenes footage putting it on was a
breeze I think it's perfect walking on
the other hand
I feel very claustrophobic now how did
you even get here honey I don't know I
can only walk very very slowly we had to
get a spray tan although I'm not even
sure why Heidi well I wanted to make
sure I look good underneath you right
inside Heidi kept your worm face on and
changed into a sparkly sheer bodysuit
Heidi's 21st Halloween bash also marked
the debut appearance for 18 year old
daughter Lenny wow it's my first time
I'm so excited I'm like shaking I'm so
excited hey this is your first I've been
begging to come for years so here I am
in Catwoman
foreign